corner of the computer, we're ready to get started. So have low everybody. It is the
14th day of November. Time is flying by. And before we do get started, I'm going to mute
everybody so we don't get feedback to begin with. Good to talk to everybody again. We are going to
open up this for questions. And I don't know why I made Aladdin our theme for the day, but it is
our theme for the day. And okay, that brings me to a funny story. My wife will kill me for telling
me this, telling you this joke, but it's one of my favorite jokes I probably told it to before. But
a man went to the beach once and rubbed a lamp and hear this GD just like this popped out and said
you get one wish. Anything you want. Here's your wish. And the man was thinking he goes, well,
I'd really love to go to Hawaii, but I'm afraid of flying. So can we? Could you build a bridge
all the way from San Francisco to Hawaii so I could drive there? That would be wonderful. I've
always wanted to go to Hawaii. And the GD said, you know, I could do just about anything, but are you
talking about a bridge all the way from San Francisco to Hawaii? That would deplete all the cement in
and all the countries on both sides of the continents. And it would it would deplete all the finances
of every country. It would ruin the economy of every country. The world would go into a worldwide
depression. It's just it's impossible. There's I there's nothing I could do about that. And then the
man said, all right, all right, all right, let me take I guess I would really, really just like to
understand women. And then the GD goes, do you want that two lanes or four lanes? Okay, so that was
really really good appropriate. So, but I thought it was funny. So anyhow, so before we get started,
just want to remind you where the exits are. So in case of an emergency, you guys could get out fast.
But it's just we're sorry. Okay, questions. Let's open this up for questions. Does anybody have any
concerns? Anything that you personally want to talk about? The the the floor is yours.
Well, this is Sharon and I'm still struggling with a site ease. And in my abdomen and when it's
around my lungs, I don't know if it's still called a site. It could be called, yep. So are you getting
it drained? Yeah, and then I just had to have a catheter pleurex catheter drain put in my
abdomen because I was needing to come too often. And the idea from my oncologist was when we find
medication that works and it starts working on the cancer, then that should subside. So I've been
kind of waiting for that. And I'm on like I was on four rounds of one type of chemo for a month. And
that didn't help it. I guy was getting worse. And then he put me on something a lot stronger. And
I've only had two infusions so far. And there's a little hint of possibly it flowing down. But I
think he was anxious to see something a little quicker happened. So I'm kind of on that fence
right now where I'm going to see in the next couple weeks, which way it's going to go. But you know,
it really makes me nervous. But I guess the question I have is I know initially if you go on a new
medication, they call it like a tumor flurry. You could get a lot of fluid because of the inflammation
from the cancer being killed off. So that could explain maybe from the beginning of a new treatment.
But then after a while, you can't keep hanging onto that. Are there patients that you know of that
have cancer that are okay? They may be stable or they may even be getting better, but they continue
to have this fluid. I just would like to know that it's not Doomsday. Like if I keep getting the fluid,
then that just means you know, well, I've had patients, I've had patients in the past have a
sighties for a long time. And it would slow down and then pick up again, slow down and pick up. So just
let's a side note here, a sighties with cancer. Physiologically, there's theories on why it happens,
but nobody knows for sure why it happens. So a sighties is fluid that is built up in the abdominal
cavity or in the plural cavity. That is the current thought is that the cell membranes are becoming
more unstable and you're getting a greater amount of fluid that's being expelled into the
extracellular spaces. So that's what the a sighties is. That's what one of the current thoughts is.
Another current thought is that it's an increase in an extracellular inflammation due to certain
immune cells called immune stimulators called cytokine increase in cytokine production
from a from a growing cancer. It's probably a mixture of those two and several other theories.
Now a sighties usually only happens in later stage and many times you go, okay, is this just like
you're saying, Jared, is this the end stage here for me? Is there a chance for recovery yet for me?
I've had patients go through really bad sighties had multiple leaders dried off and then it seems
to dry off and and slow down and then they are stable. I have some patients that are currently in that
state right now that they went through times that they had bad issues with a sighties and now it's
stabilized again. So there's, you know, hold on to that hope. Don't think it's hopeless now that you
have a sighties. I think I have some sighties of abdominal sighties not enough to get drained off
yet, but I can tell if there's some fluid in there. So it doesn't mean that it's a sighties, abdominal
sighties are plural sighties, always a bad thing. No, if you go through a different sort of therapy,
it could produce more lysis of cancer cells and that would produce sighties because you're
literally, instead of the cell going through normal apoptosis, basically a recycling of the cell
components, the cells are basically imploding or exploding or breaking down and you have this
all the cellular components just dumping into the extracellular space because the membranes are
just exploding. So one of the things that can help with the sighties is to help the health of
your cell membranes and so what are your cell membranes made up of but phospholipid by layer, a
double layer of a phosphorous group attached to a lipid. So good fat sources and that's where the
phosphatidal colline products really work well to help strengthen cell membranes so that you don't
get leakage of healthy cells because so when you do one of the theories with the sighties is that
you have this such a high ramped up cytokine production, it changes the
possibility of the extracellular spaces and your even your none cancerous cells become more leaky.
And that's where they end up producing more fluid in the extracellular space. Well that's not good
for those cells at all. The health of those cells is going down. Remember when we did your phase
angle tests in the office and we're looking at your intracellular versus extracellular fluid,
you want that to be about a 60-40 split intracellular to extracellular and when that split
reverses that's what you're going to have a greater amount of a sighties or that is a sighties,
that is a sight of greater amount of sighties and it's all due to a weakness or a damage or an
healthiness of the cell membrane itself. It can't hold the fluid. So what did you call it?
The coline. The phosphatidal coline.
And that's a supplement like that. That's a supplement and also good fats. So you're good,
you know omega-3 fatty acids. That's where the budwig protocol could be helpful in that situation.
Because that's going to be a good source of omega-6 fatty acids. I know my oncologist talked about
like low levels of protein and albumin. Yep. Kind of not helping either. So that's probably related
to what you're saying. Yep, exactly. That's changing the osmolarity of the fluid
about an albumin in the fluid. So those are some things that can help. But ultimately you want to find,
okay, if I have an increased ramp up of a sighties and I haven't changed anything in my protocol,
it's time to look at maybe I should change something in my protocol. And you are doing that,
you're changing the protocol. So is the is the lysis of the cancer cells causing the
a sighties? Well, maybe there's some of that. And like you said, I don't want to just hold on to
that hope if it's not a true hope. Well, I would consider doing some things to try to strengthen
the cell membrane. So the things that you want to consider are phosphatidal coline supplementation,
good fats even omega-3s, omega-6s doing the budwig diet. Those are things that can help.
Okay. The other thing that I would say in this situation too is I'm going to put out a video
of this hopefully in the next few days or so. So research that has been kind of ignored
out there that I found about doing weight trading for the sake of, so if I am lifting weight,
so we talk about exercise and cancer patients. Do we want to go for a five mile run? Well,
maybe not because a five mile run is going to be a highly aerobic exercise. A highly aerobic
exercise is going to burn a lot of oxygen and that's going to leave my kids or cells in a more
anaerobic state which makes kids or cells happy and they can grow faster. So we don't want to do that.
But so I've often said go out for exercise, go for a little walk and do something you would
enjoy and smell the roses and enjoy the outside and that could be an exercise. But what we're learning is
that maybe doing some weight trading, not like you're working out so hard that you're like breathing
heavy, you're going to stop and take a break because you're so tired, breath-wise. That's a
different street, tired muscle-wise, but working the muscles in using five pound weights or ten
pound weights or 20 pound weights depending on how strong you are and doing some curls and doing
some deep squats and doing some things for the muscles to call for glucose. So if the muscles call
for glucose because I'm doing a biceps curl, then you're stealing glucose from the cancer cell.
Well I was feeling like I'm lacking that exact type of exercise you explain because I've been so
you know beaten down in a week and I'm just waiting for that opportunity to even have the strength,
but you know I'm going to try to start out small as little bit of that as I can.
Yeah just get some five pound weights and do 10 curls. Yeah, part of like being weak is getting weaker
because I'm not doing any of that and it's just getting worse and I just feel like I have to break
the pattern. Yes, so I started doing you know curls and if you this was a camera you'd see how
bulky and built up I am kind of like the like the like guy right in the land right there but I
just didn't want to show off, but so that's one of the things I would suggest doing some weight
training like that that could just call get your muscles to call for glucose so that your muscles
are burning that glucose and that's going to help build muscle, it's going to help decrease
atrophy, that's going to help decrease any cakexia that's going on. So we talked about that a little
bit when we talked about had that cakexia video, but many of you didn't watch it because you're not
in cakexia. So I'm going to do a video just down weight training so that would be helpful.
But I mean I guess the bottom line is if I was kind of stable or getting better the acidity should
go away like it it should. If you're stable or getting better the acidity should go away unless you're
at a state of cell of cancer cell lysis, you just did a round of kibble that can't go that doesn't
go on forever right. All right thanks Dr. Connors, I don't know that weight training, how much
like how much stress is it put on the connective tissues that tire muscles on your bones and if you
have the bone cancer, how do you gauge that? Well if you have bone cancer actually so let's say I have
bone cancer in my humerus. So that's the bone of my upper arm right. So if I'm going to
if I use a muscle that attaches to the humerus, I will increase by using that muscle, you're pulling
out the tendon that's attached to that bone and when you pull out the tendon that attaches to that
bone, you will stimulate more calcium laid out in that bone. So there's nothing better for a person
to do than to use a muscle that attaches to the bone that they have bone cancer in. Now you have to
kind of build some anatomical things when you do that because a bicep curl would that help with
my humerus? Yes because the short head of the bicep does attach to the humerus, the deltoid
muscles attached to the humerus. So doing some deltoid exercises, however you have to be aware that
if I have bone cancer in that bone, do I want to stress it too much where I could fracture that
bone? No, but still stimulated that bone by pulling out the tendon that attaches to the bone
through use of that muscle is the best way to build bone. So if you want to build bone, pull out the
tendon that attaches to the bone, you'll stimulate an osteoblastic reaction, meaning a laid out
of calcium in that bone. So it's even more important if you have a tasticist to the bone
to use the muscles that attach to that bone. And that seems like it would strengthen the support
system surrounding the bone too? Well, it's for sure going to strengthen all the soft tissue,
but people think oh it could hurt the bone because I have cancer to that bone so I better just
laid out and do nothing. Well, that's really probably the worst thing a person could do. So if you
want to build bone even at an osteoporitic state, you have to exercise because it is literally
the pull of the tendon of the bone via the contraction of the muscle that stimulates more calcium
laid out in the bone. Well, you let pain be your guide or what? Well, you let pain be your guide
to some extent. So if I have a five out of a have metastasis to the my humorous bone and I was
able to do 25 pound curls before, it's not the amount of weight that you are doing. It's just that
pull of that. So you could use no weight and just contract the biceps and just go into a biceps
contraction like an isometric exercise where you're not actually even have any on a weight
that you're lifting, but you're using that muscle. Maybe even like those bands that you stretch with
that. Absolutely. Yep. You could do those too. Would PEMF help with the testifies bones?
In what way? PEMF is going to stimulate the muscle in with, you know, multiple electrical
stimulated. So that's going to stimulate the muscle. So that would actually stimulate
bone calcium laid out of the bone. Yes, I could see that taking place. That would be a good therapeutic
use of PEMF. Yes. Also PEMF, you know, stimulates different pathways, take away pain too. So it could
be doubly beneficial. Any other questions? This is Ken from Alaska. Yes. This is Ken from Alaska.
Hey, Ken, how are you? Pretty well. I forgot one more chemo treatment.
Six for my prostate cancer. Yeah. Next Monday, and of course, I've been doing the
RIFE machine in the protocol since June 24. Would it be wise at any time to get a re-scan
with RIFE? Yes. Okay. It would be, you just have to look at, you know, reality and be able to
come down here. It's probably colder here than it is in Alaska. Might be. Okay, so you've got a
yet to have that special red color curled tube to do that scanning, right? It's best. Yep.
Yeah, you can't do it. There's no scan built into it that I can do with the argon gas bowl.
It's not suggested that you scan with the hammer tube. It is possible, you know, anything is possible.
But, yeah, it would be good to do an extra scan just to make sure we're getting the right frequencies.
It's not, it's always good to do that. Okay. Yeah, a long trip. I'll have to think about that.
And then the ID thing, the IVG, IVG thing, that's a whole different thing. That would give us
different information wouldn't it? Yeah, and I don't think that some people need to do the IVG
that have availability of other barkers. So like somebody like you that has the availability of a PSA
as a as a valid barker of how your kids are doing. It's kind of a waste of money to do that. Okay.
But a scan might see if I needed to have the program adjusted. Exactly. Okay, all right. I'll give
that consideration. Thanks. Besides the trip, what would it cost me for just that?
That would I'd have to refer to my front desk because I don't know. Sure. Okay. All right.
Maybe I'll send them a query. Okay. Okay. Thank you for your time. Thank you.
You're back. Dr. Conner, this is Dennis Baldry. Hey, Dennis. Hi. I had a question. I had a blood test
yesterday for vitamin D. Yes. Because my doctor was concerned that I was taking 10,000 international
units a day and I was way overdosing. Yeah, you could die. Yeah. The results came back. The results
came back. But it was actually my vitamin D level was on the very low end of the the acceptable range.
Does that mean I have to look up the number. But they had a range that came at the very bottom of the
range. Okay. What would that mean? Does that have any meaning to that? So it does. So if a person
is taking vitamin D and they have still show vitamin D levels that are low, then something is going on
with autoimmune patients. Your immune system could gobble up vitamin D because it's an immune stimulant.
So it's very common with when a person has an autoimmune disorder that they have very low
vitamin D levels even though they're taking vitamin D. Secondly, as we look at a person's genetics,
you have a gene called your VDR genes, VDR. Those are your vitamin D receptor genes. And people with
defects on those end up gobbled up a lot of vitamin D and they need a higher amount of vitamin D.
If cancer patient, that's not autoimmune, that doesn't have a lot of VDR gene defects. Why would they
have low vitamin D levels even though they're taking vitamin D? There could be other factors. They
might not be absorbing it. Well, if a person has vitamin D as a fat cell, you will find them in
if the person has gallbladder issues, they might not be absorbing vitamin D very well. If they have
metastasis to bone and bone is getting mothetid, it will drop your vitamin D levels in the
need for vitamin D goes up there as well. I can't remember what supplement the exact vitamin D supplement
to your own. Could you refresh my memory? Good question. I look it up. It's like 10,000 IU today.
My test came out. Here's the results. 33 and they say the range is 31 to 100.
The typical test range is run from 30 to 80. Is there a normal range? Do they think anything over 80
is excessive? I really want my cancer patients to be over 100. I would suggest other
things too is that we might need to switch you to a vitamin D that also has A, E and K at it.
Okay. That will make it more absorbable and more usable by your tissue so you're not just
flushing it out. Okay. That might be the reason it could be a combination of the something I gave you
there. Okay, so the vitamin D, the one that we are using much more now is the ones from allergy
resource. It's vitamin D, A, E and K. It's 5,000 milligrams. 5,000 IU per capsule. I would just go
to those and still take just two a day so you're taking 10,000 a day. Okay, and that's on your website.
That vitamin D version there. Yeah. So allergy resource is the brand research. Yeah, allergy research.
I think it's yes. Okay. It's a small little bottle. I have the same problem and
hello. Yeah. I have the same issue in my oncologist said to make sure that take it with food,
not on an empty stomach, something like more fatty type food. So if you take it with a little fatty
or food that you'll stimulate bile release so that gets back to gall bladder issues. So if you're not,
if you don't have enough bile in your small intestine, it's going to make it more difficult to absorb.
Well, it's okay to just take an empty stomach. So if you that I think he's right. So if you take it with
a fat that you're going to have a better chance of secreting more bile. Okay.
Any other questions?
Time for one more.
Director Connors. This is Carla. Can you hear me? Yes.
I had sent this in by email last week so I don't know if you got it or not. But
one of my questions was with the ion pro wave. So when I do the cancer setting one,
I have like a brown and there's like a little bit of, I don't know, precipitate. And then when I do
the detox one, it's like black and I can barely see my feet at the end.
And I think you had me doing the detox one twice a week and the cancer one the rest of the days.
And I didn't know if like, if one looks worse than the other, is that an indication I should be
doing one more or not really? I don't know. That makes sense to me. So if you're doing the detox one
and it's coming out looking like tar, then probably a hint that we need to work on that a little bit more.
So remember the ion pro wave versus an ion cleanse that some of you might go to a clinic to get done
because most people don't have an ion cleanse at their house. But the ion cleanse
ionizes the water and it's going to pull a lot more minerals.
An ion pro wave isn't going to pull that many minerals. So I'm not really worried about a person
getting getting a loss of minerals and needing to supplement more minerals so much with the
ion pro wave. That's the one with the true life that most of you have at home. So you can do it every day
my point is, especially if you're drinking your greens drink, you're refreshing your body with
minerals. So you know, you're going to be fine. So yeah, if you want to do that more regularly to try
to pull some more crown out of your body, that's great. Also, would you see something like that too?
You might want to think of, do you have access to a sauna?
No. I don't. You just take other sources, other ways to try to detail.
I've been doing the coffee. Yeah, I've been doing the coffee enemas like any day that I don't have
chemo. Okay, good. 48 hours after chemo, I don't do it. But I've been doing that and I've been doing
PMF twice a week. Okay, good. But other than that, so for the foot for those ion pro waves,
maybe do the cancer one, like the detox one four times a week and the cancer one three or
yeah, you can try that. Just play with it a little bit and see if you can start getting that water
to come out a little bit clearer. Okay, sounds good. I think I had another question. Oh, I had another
question about the coffee enemas. So is it better to have less volume in longer time or more volume
in less time? It's probably better to have less volume in longer time. Okay, within reason, I mean,
you really only have to go up to 15 minutes, you know, so if you're, I've had patients do a coffee
and that have to avoid at all. Now that's a side of that they're dehydrated and they're absorbing
that water. We don't want that. So, but we want to be able to hold it for 10 to 20 minutes. That's our
goal really. So if you could do that really easy with half a quart of coffee, but then you do these
things more than that, you have to go right away. You're better off staying at half a quart.
Okay. Okay. I think that was my questions from the email. Okay, I didn't see your email at all. So,
if you, if you ever email, if anybody e-mails a question and we don't ever get to it at all,
it might have gotten lost to the abyss, so make sure you just reset it. Okay, I can do that. Thank you.
Okay, everybody. I want to give everybody a big hug. So hope everybody's doing well. No,
then I'm praying for you guys all the time. Also, if you, I know I mentioned if you have questions
to send those in. If you have any specific prayer requests, I ask that you send those in. Just put
in the subject line of the e-mails prayer requests so that all of us can be prayed for you in any
specific way that you need that you'd want to just share privately as well, because that's so so
important. So, all right. And make sure you continue to use Facebook. Ask your questions on there too.
And, um, send us any other ones you have. Thanks for participating, everybody. And I hope that
your day is well. Bye-bye, though. Thank you, Dr. Connors.
You back. Thank you, Dr. Connors. Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.